la coop un terrain gelé résumé avec
l'expression victoire tout reste à faire
victoire parce que c'est un
incontestable succès diplomatique
c'était quand même pas rien d'avoir
amené 198 fâché jamais ses 195 200 pays
à se mettre d'accord sur un texte qui
soit juridiquement contraignant au sens
onusien du terme ce qui n'est pas
juridiquement contraignant au regard du
fait dire une bombe sens ordinaire
et puis par ailleurs c'était quand même
intéressant d'avoir créé ce processus
des hyènes décès c'est à dire je déclare
ce que j'ai l'intention de faire
et puis quelque part je rentre dans une
espèce de processus itératif où à chaque
fois qu'on voit se rendre compte que
c'est pas assez
eh bien parfois un saut en demandant aux
gens d'en rajouter un peu donc ça c'est
quand même quelque chose qui n'est pas
inintéressant on va dire ça entretient
la flamme et ça entretient la flamme
dans un contexte qui ne va pas être
celui de la sanction ou de l'échec à
horizon très court le l'inconvénient de
kyoto ce qui était aussi son avantage
soit dit en passant c'est que comme
intel il mettait une contrainte en
valeur absolue sur les émissions et bien
il fallait pas attendre très longtemps
avant de savoir si ça avait fonctionné
ou pas fonctionné
du coup il y avait un intérêt c'était
que on partait pas sur un objectif dans
le vague et un inconvénient qui
effectueront la teigne et paraît basse
et encourager des gens à baisser les
bras devant voyez bien on n'y arrive pas
là l'intérêt c'est qu'on s'est mis dans
un processus
alors c'est à la fois l'intérêt la
faiblesse ses conseillers dans un
processus moins coercitif plus itératif
mais du coup qui va donner l'occasion
d'en parler à intervalles réguliers sans
nécessairement qu'à un moment donné à
bref délai on va dire on se met dans une
position où quelqu'un puisse dire pas ça
marche pas donc en rose cet écueil la
sera édité par contre si on regarde les
ces brutes
ça va devenir le verre à moitié vide les
faits bruts c'est que si on fait la
somme de tous les gens qui ont dit voilà
ce que sera ma trajectoire des missions
les émissions elles sont parties pour
augmenter pas pour baisser or il faut
savoir que si on veut vraiment respecter
l'accord les deux degrés dans le dans le
réchauffement maximal pas si on veut
avoir une chance non négligeable d'être
en dessous des 2 degrés de réchauffement
global en 2100 eh bien il faut que les
émissions soient divisées par trois
d'ici à 2050
donc entre 2015 et 2050 elles doivent en
gros perdre 3% par an et si elle va
perdre 3% par an c'est le cancer
augmente et c'est pas vraiment une bonne
idée si on fait la somme deuxième décès
à ce jour on est quand même on passe de
50 à 60 milliards de tonnes de co2
équivalent et 10 par an d'ici à 2030
donc on peut pas dire que ce soit un
vrai papa dire constant de la tâche plus
facile parce qu'on a acté sa d'aucuns
vous diront oui mais ça aurait pu monter
jusqu'à 70 ou 80 euros
ok très bien mais le fait est que ça
devrait passer de 50 à 40 c'est un vrai
sujet avec le ca passe de 50 à 60 donc
du côté du verre à moitié vide
aujourd'hui la première passe on va dire
le premier ramassage de copies et pas au
niveau de ce qu'il faudrait qu'on aime
et la deuxième faiblesse du processus
c'est que le processus est très bien
pour entretenir la flamme
mais c'est pas là que se décide d'action
parce que toutes les mesures qui vont
avoir un effet réel sur la baisse des
émissions sont à la main des états des
grandes entreprises ou des organisations
qui représentent plusieurs états ou
plusieurs entreprises et dans les
organisations qui reprennent en plus en
détails et notamment l'europe puisque
les états européens ont délégué affaires
ont consenti un abandon de souveraineté
sur un certain nombre de sujets dont les
questions environnementales à une entité
supranationale qui s'appelle l'europe et
qui gère ça
je parle aussi des ventes entreprises
parce que les grandes entreprises sont
devenus des êtres converser des êtres
qui n'existait pas au moment du traité
de westphalie qui a fondé la prééminence
des états et c'est le traité de
westphalie qui fait qu' on a toujours
conçu les mesures de réglementation de
régulation du monde à la maille des
étapes en dessous les états sont
souverains étaient de votre solidité et
à son souverain donc ça veut dire que on
peut rien concevoir au dessus des états
donc les mesures d'incitation d'
obligations fiscales etc
elles sont conçues à la maille des états
ou en dessous
aujourd'hui vous avez des êtres qui
échappent très largement à la veille des
états qui s'appelle des multinationales
le multi nationale c'est une entreprise
qui a 53 pieds dans cinquante trois
états et donc elle n'est totalement
réglementée par aucun état particulier
et c'est bien un problème en ce sens que
du coup c'est des entités qui n'ont pas
en face d'elle d'instance réglementaire
qui soit capable de les traiter dans
leur globalité
donc si je m'appelle n'importe quelle
multinationale américaine française etc
je n'ai pas en face de moi un régulateur
unique qui va j'ai un vendéen qui va
pouvoir décider de choses qui me
concerne sur la planète dans son
ensemble alors que à l'évidence il ya
quatre siècles et demi c'est quelqu'un
donc aujourd'hui on a des entités nonne
qui ne peuvent pas être traitées dans le
chaos du bien qui s'appelle les
multinationales et ses entités sont par
ailleurs les acteurs dominants
l'économie c'est celle qui font
l'innovation c'est ça qui font
l'innovation à pardies la diffuser
l'innovation en détourant dans les
petites structures par contre la
diffusion de l'innovation elle n'est
possible qu'avec la déroute donc c'est
celle qui vont diffuser les pratiques
c'est celle qui vont exercer le pouvoir
de lobby
plus fort face aux instances qui
réglemente à la marine nationale ou en
dessous et il faut absolument que ces
entités la règle entre dans la danse
pour partie et c'est toute la difficulté
de la négociation enfin plus exactement
de l'action donc il ya un premier
endroit où fait absolument trouver
matière à réaction c'est dans le monde
de l'entreprise et en particulier de la
grande entreprise il ya un deuxième
endroit où il faut trouver matière à
l'action c'est dans tout ce qui concerne
le monde de la finance dans la finance
c'est un sous-ensemble du monde de
l'entreprise on dit toujours les
entreprises et la finance dont la
finance ça fait partie des entreprises
et c'est pareil là maintenant là par la
magie des réseaux de télécommunications
et de la société de l'information
la finance est une activité apatrides
par construction il quasiment à
catherine qui en face alors là pour le
coup à des instances de régulation et
ses instances de régulation doivent
absolument être parti à faire dans la
bonne nouvelle c'est que une des
instances de régulation importante de la
finance qui est le financial stability
board
lui a commencé à s'emparer du problème
probablement parce que il est dirigé par
un homme qui est canado anglais
et que la grande bretagne fait partie
des pays qui sont globalement plutôt
quand il veut dire en avance impliqués
qui se sent concerné par les questions
de changement climatique
voilà donc la cap 21
ce qu'on peut en dire c'est elle est là
pour elle de relancer le processus de
légitimation de la question climatique à
dire ça comme ça
elle a contre elle le fait ne sait pas
elle qui a les moyens
quelle est ma part monte sur les leviers
de l'action et qu' il reste donc à faire
pour le moment d'un coq 21 a juste
décidé qu'on avait droit de faire il
reste à faire mais c'est la cave rallye
commence parce qu'on a quand même de
très loin fait plus facilement
si on prend
l'économie le pib est une sorte de
valeur ajoutée qui va des ressources
naturelles gratuite jusqu aux objets
terminé ses valeurs ajoutées comme jeudi
vont avec des transformations et c'est
là qu'intervient l'énergie parce que la
transformation en physique est là sans
unité de mesure c'est l'énergie
l'énergie mesurant physique par
définition la transformation ou plus
exactement quantifie le degré de
transformation d'un système plus un
système se transforme et plus l'énergie
appliqués dans cette transformation est
grande et inversement
plus il ya beaucoup d'énergie
mobilisables quelque part est plus à bob
une capacité de transformation
importante donc plus transforme que ya
l'énergie et c'est là qu'intervient la
dépendance des sociétés occidentales à
l'énergie en gros la production a
toujours été limitée par le plus
important de ces facteurs limitants il
ya deux siècles le plus important des
facteurs limitants et de très loin c'est
le travail humain disponible
il ya deux siècles oeillades millions
d'habitants sur terre entre 1 milliards
dont 1 milliard
la nature est immense plein de
continents sont à peine explorer
il reste des immensités vierges partout
les quelques graves ou kg ou tonnes de
minerai de fer comprend ici et les
quelques tonnes de charbon comprend là
c'est vraiment pas un sujet au regard de
l'immensité de l'environnement et les
quelques tonnes de co2 jazzar par le
postérieur à ce moment là sont vraiment
pas un sujet et les quelques kilos de
cochonneries que les romains déversés
dans les rivières au titre de leurs
tannerie primitive
ça faisait sentir à beauvais à côté mais
enfin il ya les bières australiennes
n'était pas spécialement gêné par
l'activité de tenri qui pourrait y avoir
en italie donc il ya à ce moment-là
l'environnement est immense et la seule
limite à la transformation de
l'environnement par les hommes pour
faire la production c'est la quantité
d'hommes et le capital humain accumulé
prenons l'époque des moulins ce qui
limite la quantité de grains que je peux
faire pousser puis moudenc
c'est pas les surfaces cultivables ne
sait pas ce qui peut dans l'année c'est
serra c'est juste la quantité d'hommes
qui peuvent planter du grain et récolté
et la quantité de boue large dispose
d'accords donc ce qui est facteur
limitant de la production avant la
révolution industrielle
c'est combien d'hommes peuvent penser
qu'elle est capital humain accumuler
puis arrive la révolution industrielle
où on va remplacer les hommes par des
machines parce que ça qu'on fait or
quand on remplace un homme par une
machine en moyenne aujourd'hui en france
on multiplie par cinq cent la capacité
de transformation
si les ouvriers qui construisent des
voitures devaient martelé les tôles à la
main sous des habits avec une avec comme
comme dans l'ancien temps avec juste une
forge un soufflet de forge et je passe
les pièces je les rougis offert je
dépose sais pas quoi dessus et puis on
craque je passe à la portière d'après
s'il devait transporter à dos d'homme
d'avoir une chaîne qui fasse défiler des
objets devant eux si etc la production
annuelle du zune d'une usine de voitures
seraient divisés par n'importe quoi
entre 1000 et solide quand on aura une
production artisanale de voitures à
chaque voiture coûte en mille fois plus
cher qu'aujourd'hui donc la raison pour
laquelle la production a augmenté c'est
pas parce que les ouvriers se sont ils à
avoir comme silva 25 paires de bras et
quarante deux paires de jambes c'est
juste parce que aujourd'hui un ouvrier
il ne produit pas par lui-même il
commande une machine qui produit tous
nous commençons aujourd'hui les machines
qui produisent le boulanger commande son
pétrin le chauffeur livreur commande son
camion le consultant comme moi commande
son ordinateur et commande à distance un
réseau télécoms etc et les gens qui
travaillent dans le domaine du nucléaire
il commande des engins 2000 pour
extraire de l'uranium et il commande des
centrifugeuses et ils commandent des
pompes des vannes des clapets des
machins mes trucs et des bidules et
caetera et caetera et les gens du
creusot loire elle commande détresse a
forgé qui font parfois grand bruit dans
la presse donc c'est ça le métier
aujourd'hui des hommes c'est le
commander des machines soit dit en
passant ça explique pourquoi quand on
diminue l'approvisionnement énergétique
quelque part on diminue la quantité de
machines qui peuvent travailler et du
coup tout emploi étant devenus
dépendants d'une machine dont 10,1
pauvres dont contrairement à une idée
couramment répondu quand on divise
l'approvisionnement énergétique quelque
part on remplace par la machine par
l'homme parce que la machine peut plus
fonctionner différentiel de productivité
du bout
rue entre les deux c'est pas ça qui se
passe c'est qu'on remplace des machines
avec des gens qui les font fonctionner
par pas de machines et les chômeurs
et c'est ce qu'on est en train
d'observer dans tous les pays d'europe
occidentale et les états unis et le
japon depuis 2007 mais on y reviendra
peut-être après donc le jeu fini mon
explication sur la macroéconomie donc ce
qui permet de transformer c'est
l'énergie
et bien aujourd'hui le différentiel de
productivité encore une fois entre les
hommes et les machines du tellement
important que le premier facteur
limitant à la transformation qui va
donner le pib ça n'est plus le nombre de
gens au travail et du reste il ya des
gens au travail surabondance partout et
ce qu'on appelle du chômage et
réductible
ça n'est pas le capital humain accumuler
aujourd'hui les usines tournent à 60 70
% de leurs facteurs de charge il ya de
l'argent partout
tous les banquiers savent pas quoi faire
de leur argent c'est l'énergie
disponible pour faire tourner le parc de
machines c'est ça qui est devenu le
premier facteur limitant des industries
occidentales enfin des pays occidentaux
vers midi industrialisés
si on manque d'énergie et on sort
pas de lien entre le prix de l'énergie
et la quantité disponible mais je
reviendrai après donc là il ya aussi un
truc qu'il faut jeter par la fenêtre qui
est la vieille idée sympathique qui est
que s'il ya moins d'énergie ça vaut plus
cher c'est vrai instantanément
c'est faux à moyen long terme
donc à chaque fois que sur
l'approvisionnement pétrolier par
exemple il ya une rupture de pente
il ya eu un choc qui a duré quelques
années et après le prix a fait
exactement ce qu'il avoue donc là
l'élasticité prix volume de s'applique
que les premières années du manque
d'énergie
après ça s'applique plus ça a été
vraiment 74 riant 79 vrai en 2007 vrai
en 2014
hélas aujourd'hui on est en décrue
pétrolière subi en termes
d'approvisionnement en volume et ça ne
se traduit pas les prix parce qu'il n'ya
pas d'élasticité prix volume de l'auteur
et pour savoir qui a pas de nécessité
prix volume c'est très simple il suffit
de faire un graphique que j'ai fait sur
lequel on met en 26 la quantité de
pétrole consommé dans le monde en
ordonner le prix du baril et on regarde
aussi les points sa ligne de telle sorte
que plusieurs pétrole disponible et
moins et vos chères et moyens d'être
indisponible et plus il vaut cher et
c'est pas du tout comme ça qu'est mois
s'organise donc c'est très facile de
dire hier à l'élasticité prix volume
donc pour en revenir à mon énergie qui
pilotent l'activité depuis 2007 les pays
de l' ocde sont tous passés par un
maximum en approvisionnement énergétique
ce faire le maximum de
l'approvisionnement énergétique dans les
pays de cds étaient 2006 à peu près
partout
pourquoi 2006 parce qu'en 2005 le
pétrole arrête de croître dans le monde
la production mondiale de pétrole
s'arrête de croître et comme le pétrole
est la première des énergies consommées
dans les pays ocde l'approvisionnement
des pays ocde qui doivent partager avec
les consommateurs domestiques des
producteurs et qu'ils doivent partager
avec les hébergeant l'approvisionnement
des pays de céder au sommaire décroître
et comme c'est le premier terme de
l'approvisionnement de ces pays
leurs approvisionnements
ti global se faire décroître et dans
tous les pays dossier depuis le taux
d'emploi des croix c'est à dire la
fraction de la population adulte qui a
un emploi
la production industrielle des croix
sauf aux états unis où c'est reparti
transitoirement à la hausse à cause de
l'exploitation du shell oil et du shale
gas mais le reste du secteur
manufacturier n'est pas revenu au niveau
de 2007
hélas le secteur chez lush ndiass au
moment où on se parle il est déjà de
nouveau emprunter croître sa cause des
bas prix
partout ailleurs ça décroît et même la
grande bretagne qui est en train de
retrouver un pays d élevées c'est parce
qu'ils ont 80 % services financiers
enfin 80% de services dont plein de
services financiers leur production
industrielle continue à décroître
donc toute la production industrielle
des pays de l'osce et des oeufs décroît
depuis 2007 parce que les pays ocde sont
en stress d'approvisionnement
énergétique depuis 2007
ce stress n'y a pas suffisamment vite
pour que couplé à la croissance des
émergents en sauve le climat
par contre il est déjà suffisamment
présent pour que ça interdisent de
penser la transition énergétique dans un
contexte de croissance
donc on se retrouve dans la tenaille que
alain grandjean et votre serviteur avait
identifié dès 2006 dans un précurseur de
ce bouquin qui a fait le plein s'il vous
plaît où on expliquait que si on
attendait on n'aurait pas le monde
merveilleux forever avec une économie
qui va de mieux en mieux et des
emmerdements qui sont dans le journal
toujours pour plus tard on finirait par
se retrouver dans une tenaille dans
lequel on aurait de moins en moins
d'énergie disponibles pour faire face à
de plus en plus dans l'ère de man et
bien en europe ça a commencé
je suis un grand partisan de l'énergie
nucléaire notamment pour remplacer le
charbon mais si on pouvait avoir une
énergie nucléaire illimité sur terre ce
serait une catastrophe absolue parce que
mines énergie illimitée ça veut dire que
demain matin si mon voisin m'emmerde je
suis capable d' ériger une montagne
entre lui et moi te dire qu on devient
tous superman donc la terre sombre dans
un combat de titans permanent je suis
pas sûr que ce soit un avenir radieux
donc je suis fais en ce moment contre l'
énergie illimitée pense qu'il faut
surtout pas chercher à faire ça ce qu'il
faut chercher à faire ce qui est
beaucoup plus difficile soit dit en
passant c'est de s'accommoder d'une
énergie limitée ne veut pas dire d'une
énergie nul mais rejet limité à un
moment il faut savoir se poser la
question qui est rare machistes ou match
et d'une manière générale on a dans
notre monde moderne un problème
fondamental de rapport à la limite dans
les temps anciens ont considéré la
limite comme normal donc vous ne trouvez
pas dans les temps anciens le texte qui
explique que c'est ce qu'on va le
demeurer à 90 ans parce qu'il a fait
trop chaud
vous ne trouvez pas que c'est absolument
scandaleux d'avoir laissé quelqu'un
vivre sans toi
vous pouvez éventuellement trouver que
c'est pas sympathique pour les gens
concernés mais en gros l'état normal du
monde c'était qu'on pouvait pas tout
avoir
point à mon sens et là je pense que je
vais je vais reformuler du taux de ville
d'une autre manière
à mon sens c'est la démocratie qui a
fait naître cette ce sentiment
d'insatisfaction perpétuelle en tout cas
tôt ville considère que la démocratie
fait d'être de la satisfaction car pitt
ul sur la base d'arguments qui était si
simple il dit si tout le monde est égal
sur la ligne de départ
toute personne qui n'est pas qu'ils
voient quelqu'un plus avancés sur la
ligne d'arrivée va considérer que c'est
injuste dont caen rouen démocratie tant
qu'il reste quelqu'un qui a plus que
vous vous considérez que ça va pas
caricature un peu mais il ya quelque
chose de sain alors que dans les temps
anciens en aristocratie on avait affaire
à un univers figé donc vous étiez
fataliste et vous accompagner de votre
sort
la démocratie fait naître ce sentiment
d'injustice de manière beaucoup plus et
du tout cas c'est ce que dit oblige mais
je suis assez d'accord avec lui et du
coup ça veut dire que vous allez
chercher à repousser la limite en
permanence puisque toute limite est une
injustice machin il boira sentant moi je
vais mourir à 80 ans c'est dégueulasse
bidule gagner 1000 euros par an mois par
mois par dont trois qui regagne mille
c'est scandaleux s'est donc associé m'a
un jour dit la définition du minimum
vital très simple c'est qui que ce soit
qui répondent c'est c'est ce que gagne +
10 %
voilà je pense que c'est une assez bonne
vision de la façon dont on réagit dans
un univers de liberté on considère que
puisqu'on était chacun libre de faire ce
qu'on voulait on est en particulier
libre d'avoir une chose que doyen six
voisins à + marvel libre devant la même
chose ces constructions pendant c'est
une conception très extensive de la
liberté laissée pendant donc le ferez
suggère ma vie il est là il est comment
est ce que je fait coexister la
démocratie ou quelque chose qui y
ressemble
avec le fait qu'on accepte
collectivement des limites et qu'on se
dit un jour au moins wima mourir à 80
ans c'est normal qu'ils m'aident à 70
ans c'est normal et sont pas un sujet
point et ça aujourd'hui c'est les débats
inexistant et à mon avis et des débats
de fond dans le fait qu'on arrive à
faire quelque chose de durable ou pas
l'énergie fossile elle nous a ramené
quelque chose pour en revenir à la
physique qui est un facteur
multiplicatif qu'à mon avis on ne
retrouvera jamais une fois qu'on sera
sorti des fossiles donc elle nous a
amené ce fameux facteur multiplicatif de
500 entre la puissance du parc de
machines et la puissance des hommes dans
les pays occidentaux
tant qu'on était sans énergie fossile
c'était très simple pays et d'un pays
était proportionnel à sa population
puisque chaque homme était en gros à peu
près aussi productifs que le voisin donc
vous avez que vos bras et aux jambes
bah un paysan chinois ils n'ont pas
cultiver le blé 25 fois plus vite qu'un
paysan français aucun paysan américain
aucun paysan brésilien tout ça va à peu
près vitesse en artisans qui fabriquent
des poteries il n'est pas 50 fois plus
efficaces au mexique l'île de l'air en
egypte donc bon an mal an vous prenez la
population d'un pays vous avez son pib
raison pour laquelle soit dit en passant
la chine a une envie de retrouver une
position dominante qu'elle a occupée
pendant 2000 ans parce que pendant 2000
ans elle a eu la première population
mondiale et donc elle a eu le premier
pib mondial
donc le les combustibles fossiles ont
amené une énergie permettant d'alimenter
des machines avec une simplicité
d'utilisation a dû l'autre paris et en
particulier la reine des énergies
fossiles qui est le pétrole quand on est
allé des énergies renouvelables qui
étaient celles qui sauront utiliser
puisque la civilisation humaine a
démarré avec quand elle a lu accès à
l'énergie avec le feu il ya deux
millions d'années en gros qui a permis
d'abord d'éloigner des prédateurs
ensuite d'organiser la chasse est très
longtemps derrière sauf etc
puis elle a utilisé la traction animale
renouvelables l'énergie du vent faire
avancer les bateaux et tourner les
moulins renouvelables énergie
chutes d'eau pour faire tourner les
moulins à renouvelables l'énergie du
soleil je l' ai déjà dit pour alimenter
faut faire pousser des végétaux pour
alimenter des animaux de trait tout ça
c'est en plein jeu reste qu'on essaye de
refaire aujourd'hui et c'est ce qui a
permis c'est quand on est passé de cette
énergie parfaitement renouvelables est
parfaitement durable à l'énergie fossile
qu'on a connu l'explosion de la sphère
industrielle
je n'ai jamais fait un calcul d'ordre de
grandeur qui met convaincus du fait qu
on allait garder ça avec uniquement des
oeillères
gnr sont une alternative par
crédible si on ne met pas dans le cahier
des charges on rentre on observer le
niveau de consommation actuelle si la
population dans sa grande sagesse et
ayant bien compris le problème dit mais
je m'en fous de conserver niveau
consommation actuelle j'accepte de vivre
dans un logement
quatre fois plus petit pas toujours
chauffer c'était de plus avoir de
manière aucun problème voilà
soit dit en passant je pense que de
toute façon un jour on arrivera là avec
la décrue des énergies fossiles subi ou
gérer de toute façon il restera pas un
jour une bagnole par personne en âge de
conduire comptant dix mille euros à
l'achat et roulant à 150 km une partie
de sa ré disparaître même avec la
voiture électrique une partie de sa ré
disparaître il restera pas des freins
que vous pouvez vous acheter en soldes
pour 15 euros la robe et 20 euros la
veste comme on le voit aujourd'hui et
des chaussures que vous pouvez vous
acheter pour 15 euros tout ça va
disparaître
par contre si on veut une civilisation
basée sur l'énergie renouvelable où on
se contente d'une paire de chaussures
achetées tous les 10 ans d'un pantalon
halte et tous les dictateurs ya aucun
problème aucun donc le très neuf
aujourd'hui celle qu'est ce qu'on veut
en plus de ça et si on veut en plus de
ça et sans faux cils le nucléaire arrive
à manca bleus mandela
moi ce que je dis c'est le nucléaire
entretient un système de consommation
plus forte que si on a juste des jeux et
n'être maintenant entre le niveau de
consommation aujourd'hui qui n'est pas
soutenable est quelque chose qui est au
dessus de ce qu'avait un paysan et les
deux siècles vraisemblablement qu en se
remuant un peu en un moyen de trouver un
équilibre qui existe mais c'est très
différent de dire on va maintenir le
niveau des flux actuel parce que de
toute façon si vous y arrivez sur
l'énergie vous aller buter sur
l'approvisionnement en métaux vous a
débuté sur les terres arables vous aller
buter sur l'érosion des sols vous aller
buter sur les matériaux de carrières et
le but est donc en gros tout ça va se
prennent et donc moi je vous laisse le
premier revers le problème tel que je le
place est le suivant ce qui m'intéresse
c'est pas tellement le paysage à terme
parce que le paysage à terme d'un
deuxième en trois siècles gens c'est
[ __ ] en rien ce qui m'intéresse c'est
la dérive et c'est à dire la dynamique
sur laquelle on doit se placer pour
passer dès qu'on va devoir passer avant
que vous soyez mort enfin en tout cas je
vous le souhaite
peut-être même avant que moi je sors
encore qu'en 2050 suis pas sûr que
j'aurais encore un cerveau de ted
si j'existe encore donc là est la
question médailles qu'on peut passer
c'est celle de la division par 3 des
émissions
si on veut éviter d'avoir un
réchauffement climatique qui va mettre
la planète à feu vert sans
quand vous regardez l'intensité
capitalistique comparée du nucléaire sur
lequel fois qu'on vienne quand même
parce qu'en ce moment on est quand même
en train de déconner dans l'évent de
l'argent en france et enfin ça fait 20
ans qu'on décolle dans les grandes
largeurs un peu plus précis et le les
renouvelables intermittentes avec du
stockage associées il y a aucune chance
que mes enfants connaissent un monde en
paix si on se dit c'est les nerfs avec
stockage on va utiliser aucune
j'ai fait quelques calculs de coin de
table en gros si on veut remplacer le
système français par des éoliennes avec
des barrages faut construire quelques
milliers de barrages de silence en de
grandeur il faut multiplier par un
facteur 3 la puissance de pointe que le
réseau peut encaisser et il faut
multiplier par 10 à 20 les capitaux
injectés dans le système pour produire
la même quantité d'électricité à
l'arrivée dit autrement là où le coût de
reconstruction à neuf du système
français coûte 300 à 400 milliards
d'euros avec un système éolien a pu
stockage ça va ce ballet des quelque
part entre 3000 et 6000 milliards
d'euros on les a pas 1,5 à 3 fois le pib
français
on les a peints on ne les a pas et même
pas la peine d'essayer de les chercher
on baissa pas donc ça veut dire que si
on essaye de faire ça on en a rien rien
donc un pays il va s'effondrer plus vite
que souhaitable et donc on aura le
bordel donc essayer de faire ça en ce
moment dire qu'on va se récupérer une
dictature c'est à peu près pareil je
pèse mes mots 1
c'est à peu près pareil de même que dire
qu'on va résoudre le problème du charbon
dans le monde en y allant avec du
solaire du stockage et de l'éolien c'est
aller droit vers la multiplication c'est
aller droit vers un réchauffement
climatique a accéléré et la
multiplication d'un monde hostile
violent guerrier j'en ai pas envie
et soit dit en passant d'une dégradation
de la biodiversité bien supérieure à ce
montant à 6 on a
une centrale qui tente en fait n'importe
quoi tous les 20 ans donc c'est un cd
risque comparer qui font qu'aujourd'hui
la question pour moi se pose pas de
savoir si le nucléaire à entretenir at
vitam aeternam une civilisation de
l'excellent aujourd'hui mon problème
c'est est ce qu'il faut pas mettre le
nucléaire
pardon d'expression à toute vapeur au
service du remplacement des bills 800
gigawatts de centrales à charbon qu'on
avant le monde qui doivent être
dézinguer en 35 ans c'est ça la question
une fois qu'on a fait ça on se posera la
question pareille mais tant qu'on n'a
pas fait ça la question de la praye pour
moi elle ne se pose même pas s'il y aura
pas d'après
en france ça fait 20 ans que en gros le
nucléaire est honteux dit autrement on
en fait mais si ça pouvait être pas
savoir c'est quand même bien et ça fait
20 ans que le politique et avec la
filière dans une négociation qui est je
vous le jeu je vous sais que je sacrifie
un os totémique donc ça a été super
phénix c'est fessenheim vous blessez
sacrifier une jeune vierge pour dire
quand même que c'est quelqu'un et puis
pour le reste faites et puis ne le dites
pas trop fort en gros c'est ça
et alors sa structure est plein de
travers dans la filière d'abord ça a
créé un réflexe corporatiste
au delà de ce qui était souhaitable
parce que quand vous vous sentez un peu
vulnérable vous serrer les coudes et
donc du coup ça a créé j'ai plein de
défenseurs que la filière nucléaire
l'excès inverse ou un excès qui est que
les gens sont devenus aussi psychorigide
parfois que les gens qu'ils avaient en
face donc il croit que dans le nucléaire
plein de salut qu'il ya que ça qui
compte comme sujet que ça fait donc ils
sont parfois aussi fille corinne qu'en
face et s'est pas laissée par le
syndrome cordes évident c'est le
syndrome citadelle assiégée
ce qui est très différent ça a créé un
deuxième effet pervers c'est que du coup
on a laissé dans la filière des erreurs
stratégiques se produire et je pense
qu'en particulier il y en a une qui a
été lourde de conséquences et je ne veux
pas jeter la pierre à telle ou telle
personne en particulier parce que
j'étais pas là où la décision a été
prise je ne sais pas qui est responsable
et à limite c'est pas le sujet et je
pense qu'il ya eu une erreur
fondamentale en laissant areva à
franchir deux marches à la fois c'est à
dire en créant à la fois un nouveau
modèle de réacteur et un nouveau métier
donc ou bien arriver à créer un nouveau
modèle de réacteur et continuer à être
dans un deal où je fais l'îlot nucléaire
mais je ne sais pas la maîtrise d'oeuvre
ça c'était une marche à la fois ou bien
arriver à disait je reste sur la
génération 2
et je fais la maîtrise d'oeuvre et à ce
moment je ne fais pas un nouveau modèle
de réacteur mais d'avoir voulu faire les
deux à la fois où surplus avec un degré
de compétitivité croissante qui était
pas idiot dans le principe sauf que qui
était de s'allier avec siemens et de
d'empiler les uns sur les autres les
exigences de sûreté française et
exigences de sûreté allemande et cetera
abouti à quelque chose qui aujourd'hui
est une espèce de j'ai pas dire monstre
parce que ça serait pas gentil mais
quand même ça a quelque chose de ça
c'est à dire un objet qui est devenu
monstrueusement compliqué à gérer
et avec tous les problèmes qui sont des
problèmes très classique des premiers du
genre tels que celui qu'on a eus alkylée
auto ou dans une moindre mesure à
flamanville quand vous faites plusieurs
trucs nouveaux à la fois la probabilité
pour sur un objet aussi complexe avec un
réacteur nucléaire la probabilité pour
vous preniez pas it all est absolument
nulle on a eu un deuxième sujet qui est
venue se greffer là-dessus c'est que
quand vous dites à une filière fait
votre truc dans votre coin mais moi je
dirais pas que c'est bien vous l'a privé
d'une partie de sa base arrière d'où les
échecs à l'exportation parce que à
pareille époque où ça va coûter un bras
parce que les investisseurs pensent que
c'est risqué et apartisan ou à mon avis
les chinois ils ont acheté tout ce
qu'ils trouvaient sur le marché histoire
de pouvoir faire des comparaisons le
fait est que la france devant plus à
l'export alors que c'était quand même
une de ses forces avant ça aboutit à des
coûts de sûreté ce que le coût du
nucléaire d'un coup la sûreté en eau
en plus de la réaction de fission qui
vaut le coup technique de faire un coeur
et de mettre du combustible de dans tout
le reste c'est cool la précaution tout
le reste c'est cool la précaution plus
vous avez peur et plus le sentiment de
peur est entretenu par un pouvoir
politique qui dit c'est caca plus
l'exigence de précaution sera élevé plus
le coût de la précaution est élevé plus
ce qui permet derrière soi dit en
passant veut dire vous avez vu arriver
bien un groupe vous dire que c'était
kaka ça coûte un bras
le monde est là c'est pareil ça fait 20
ans qu'on est infructueux d'avoir dans
ce pays un débat adultes sur à quel
moment et ce qu'on dit stop là on en a
fait assez parce que ça sert à rien d'en
rajouter 30 milliards ont continué à
laisser les cigarettes en vente libre
donc il ya un moment où on a une
disproportion totale entre le coût de la
précaution et le bénéfice de la
précaution or je sais de source sûre
puisque j'ai posé la question au
titulaire du poste qu' il n'entre pas
dans le mandat de l'asn de faire une
analyse coûts bénéfices des mesures
mises en oeuvre par l'asn
c'est pas de la responsabilité de son
patron c'est de la responsabilité de
celui qui fait le moins mal de l'asn moi
je pense que ça devrait être un pull je
suis patron chef d'entreprise
à aucun moment je n'ai externalise le
coût bénéfice de faire ou de ne pas
faillir à chaque fois que je décide de
faire de ne pas faire je me pose la
question du coup la question du bénéfice
et j'arbitre je vais jamais au grand
jamais arbitré sur la seule question du
bénéfice sans me poser la question du
coût fillon demain matin je fais une opé
assure total et des avions
il faut dire en effet que c'est donc
dans le domaine du nucléaire
je me dis me semble qu'il ya des trucs
qui est important est de mettre dans le
mandat de l'asn
le fait d'avoir une analyse coûts
bénéfices pour l'évolution du
référentiel de sûreté
alors des fois ils vous diront on sait
pas c'est difficile il n'y a pas de
branques une statistique très bien mais
je pense que quand même on en sentira
des choses
donc on est en train de dégrader la
qualité de notre actif en continuant à
le gérer comme de l'à-peu-près enfin
dans l'à peu près et à faire des
tractations politiques à la petite
semaine sur le dos d'un truc qui marche
qui marchait bien et c'est totalement
irresponsable
non ce n'est pas le seul domaine dans
lequel les tractations à la petite
semaine sont irresponsables et enfin son
état et sans d'état qui va être
particulièrement lourd de conséquences
parce que on est dans un domaine dans
lequel imaginons que l'asn 10 il ya
quatre réacteurs en france qui passe pas
la rampe des quarante ans ben vous avez
4 rectangles il avait parlé de
construire un coach choisira pas le
pognon pour mettre les éoliennes et les
machins les âmes et les allemands ils
s'amusent à faire ça les allemands ils
ont remplacés sauf erreur de ma part il
avait que je dise pas de conneries 32
gigawatts instaura troy est installée
nucléaire nucléaire ils en ont remplacé
huit après fukushima
et pour remplacer les 8 gigawatts de
nucléaire qui va là les trois foyers de
24,4 feuilleton de les diviser par 2 15
milliards d'euros de valeur amorti parce
que il avait quand même déjà bien servi
ils ont investi 300 milliards d'euros
dans les 1ères donc vous avez un rapport
de 1 à 20 quand je parlais tout à
l'heure
l'allemagne était et est un band
expérimentation grandeur nature pour mon
sexe est à peu près sa robe de grandeur
alors si vous évacuez si vous dites
qu'en fait il faut comparer à la valeur
à neuf
vous êtes d'ailleurs à près de 1 à 10 si
vous dites qu'il faut évacuer
l'électricité exportée parce qu'en fait
la moitié des 1 er conduisent à des
exportations fatale un peu de vent sous
le soleil brille si vous dites que vous
des falic et le et des légionnaires
exporter et que les gens consomment que
la moitié ou garder ça ça fait encore un
rapport de 1 à 10
donc le rapport de maradi ça va je
parlais tout à l'heure les amours ongles
observe ces paroles justes l'esprit est
bien en france si vous déclassé sauf que
les amants ils ont 200 milliards d'euros
de solde exportateur par an ce n'est pas
la même histoire que la france qui elle
a quelques dizaines de milliards d'euros
de déficit commercial
donc si vous mettez à la ferraille
n'importe quoi entre 4 10 réacteurs
parce que ça passe par des quarante ans
le résultat net de la faire c'est pas du
tout que ça va être remplacé par des
éoliennes c'est que sar est remplacé par
rien et comme ça va être remplacé par
rien alors que l'approvisionnement
électrique est indispensable à la
continuité du fonctionnement de plein de
trucs partout vous aurez une récession
sauvage très exactement ce que vous
aurez alors on peut dire que c'est
souhaitable
moi je suis pas en train de dire c'est
pas souhaitable je suis juste en train
de dire
c'est la contrepartie il ya des gens qui
souhaitent sauter du premier étage la
tour eiffel la contrepartie c'est qu'ils
y restent comme le souhaitait juste
l'idée qu'on va sauter du premier étage
et que une fois contrarié par terre on
ira dîner au restaurant l'yonne
ça marche pas bon voilà c'est exactement
pareil peut souhaiter avoir quatre
biréacteurs qui disparaissent du paysage
la contrepartie c'est qu'on aura une
récession sauvage fois ci c'est ça les
termes du choix des gens rigolent ce que
je discute dans cette affaire et c'est
ça tout le thème du bouquin c'est le
malentendu sur le fait que l'on
s'imagine qu'on va avoir le beurre et
l'argent du beurre et tout parti
sympathique de la crémière entre bon ça
en nombre
à quoi ressemblera le moment de 1100 à
tout sauf à ce qu'on s'imagine
aujourd'hui c'est le première forme de
réponse
2 il n'est pas nécessaire de savoir à
quoi ressemblera le monde dans deux
mille cent en 2000 sans pardon pour
savoir ce qui serait souhaitable de
faire dès aujourd'hui pour limiter le
risque qui ressemble à quelque chose de
pas sympathique dix autres je vais
prendre un parallèle j'ai des enfants je
vous en avais déjà les enfants jeunes et
foutrement aucune idée de là où seront
les enfants dans 30 ans par contre j'ai
une idée très claire de ce qu'il
m'appartient de faire demain la semaine
prochaine dans un mois et dans un an
pour faire en sorte que leur vie soit
poussé plutôt du bon côté que du mauvais
je me trompe peut-être soit dit en
passant mais au moins j'ai une idée très
claire
j'avais dit est très clair quand les
enfants étaient petits que c'était
plutôt une bonne idée de leur apprendre
à manger avec une cuillère plutôt
qu'avec leurs droits bon peut-être que
c'était une mauvaise idée dit qu'on a
besoin de cuillères qu'il faut fabriquer
et d'allergies machin mais bon pour leur
insertion sociale à court terme
c'est vrai qu'en france c'est plutôt
mieux il ya des pays où c'est un dieu et
les pays où c'est normal de manger que
ses doigts voilà en france
donc j'avais une idée très claire de ce
qu'il fallait faire 2 pourquoi je les
fais ça ne veut pas dire que je savais
vous serez défi phare temps après donc
il ya des choses qui vous paraissent sur
lesquels la décision est simple
apprendre et pour autant vous n'avez pas
besoin pour l'apprendre de savoir où
vous en serez dans 50 ans eh ben je n'ai
pas besoin de savoir à quoi ressemblera
le monde en 2100 pour savoir qu'il
faudrait à la ferraille les centrales à
charbon
j'ai pas besoin j'ai pas besoin de
savoir à quoi ressemblera le monde en
2100 pour dire qu' il faut préserver la
biodiversité
j'ai pas besoin de savoir à quoi ça
ressemblera pour dire qu'il faut
préserver des simples cultivables j'ai
pas besoin de savoir pour dire que etc
il ya un certain nombre de trucs pour
lesquels on n'a pas besoin de savoir
pour avoir une idée très claire de la ou
de là où va pencher l'action aujourd'hui